Israel se prepara para un nuevo capítulo
en su conflicto político Este martes el
país celebrará su quinta elección en
menos de 4 años donde el foco central
está puesto en si benjaminyahu podrá
retomar al poder
este tenía volverán Yahoo el poder Esa
es la pregunta que los israelís piensan
hoy pero creo que esta ronda no se trata
solo de netanyahoo
su único contendiente de peso es el
Primer Ministro interino y Air lapid
quien debió Cesar al gobierno de naftalí
bennett y Llamar a elecciones tras
perder su exigua mayoría en el
parlamento
ciudadanos israelíes estamos ante
ustedes hoy en un momento que no es
fácil pero entendemos que tomamos la
decisión correcta para Israel
las encuestas no dan a netanyahu ni a
lapid la ventaja suficiente para evitar
formar coaliciones ambos cuentan con una
llave para desbloquear la situación
Aunque el panorama es beneficioso para
netan Yahoo
y tamar bengavir un parlamentario de
extrema derecha con pasado apoyando
grupos terroristas se perfila como
tercera posición y podría ser el
desbloqueo de netan Yahoo para lapid el
actual ministro de defensa benigans
puede ser el Aliado clave en este
escenario gran parte de la ciudadanía
israelí cree que ninguno de los dos
candidatos es la solución hija
ni siquiera sé por quién votar es
terriblemente confuso y no siento que
pueda confiar en nadie
quien inventan los comicios de ver
acumular al menos 61 escaños para formar
un gobierno espera un país con un
creciente costo de vida y tensos lazos
con Palestina Irán y los grupos jamás y
hezbolá